was it like growing up with jordan as  your dad imagine if your entire  childhood you spent watching jordan  peterson youtube videos my dad is really  a lot like he is on youtube if you've  seen any of his lectures or looked at  his old courses that was kind of what  dinner table conversation was like i  learned a lot about psychology i know a  lot about personality i didn't know it  was weird until i was like 24 or until  he got famous and then i realized it was  weird we had 37 different colors of  paint in our house over 100 paintings  all the walls were completely covered in  soviet art i once had a lenin painting  fall on me while i was sleeping